oh yes young how's it going everyone as
you know
i am the biggest bts fan and you know
what
i forgive them for unfollowing me on
twitter
it was three years ago i don't even use
twitter anymore
i forgive young cook i forgive
it's over and you might think felix how
can you be the biggest bts stan
because i understand bts okay but
there's one
bts stain that might have me trump and
that is of course
the one the only holly london
ollie's been posting a lot lately
ollie's been uh
very busy there's a message for dr phil
so i've just completed my transition to
look korean to look just like jimin
this i think is my final procedure so
i'm so so happy
to share this with you even though
you're probably gonna be so
mad at me like i know you're gonna go
crazy at me
um next time you see me just because you
told me not to do anything
you told me to love the real me the love
the real ollie and
uh i did take your advice for like a
year but then
i kind of just uh changed my mind so
please don't be mad at me dr phil but
i'm so happy to have transitioned
from british to korean i'm now
say that again your transition rate
is that what we're doing now can you
imagine someone transitions to be
swedish
why would why would you do that why
would you do this
oh god okay so for those who don't know
or don't remember
i did a video on ali i think a year ago
two years ago
this is what ali used to look like and
this is ollie today oh gosh even then
it's like
well i guess you know he just came out
from surgery
so you're bound to look a bit scuffed my
nose is very big
it's horrible i can't it's very hard to
look at it so ollie is obsessed with
jimin from bts and wants to be exactly
like him
dollars on numerous surgeries can't feel
his face
all to look like his k-pop idol jimin
he wants to look like jimin oh oh
oh
oh god it's such a strange story and
it's just getting weirder
so now ollie came out after another
surgery
trying to bait dr phelan hey guys but
this is his latest update to
um you know come out today something
that's been like
on my mind for a long time and i've been
very confused about how i identify
i've been very really haven't picked up
any hints of that whatsoever
maybe you don't have to identify
maybe you be you identify with self
i've seen a lot of other people online
that have come out and been very brave
about it
and show who all else has come out
as korean i need to know this
this cannot be a thing this can not be a
thing they identify
their gender their pronouns etc sure
yeah no i've taken courage from these
incredibly brave um people and it is
pride month at the moment so
you know i thought this was the best
time to do it um oh [ __ ] i just noticed
that
the likes of this like jesus christ all
right and then add add a voice add
strength to the lgbtq plus i
community um so i am gonna come out
today and say that i've been
transitioning i've been very unhappy
with
who i am deep down um for the last eight
years and i've
you know i've had like 18 plastics so
you've been happy for
the last eight years and you've done 18
surgeries then maybe
just maybe the surgeries isn't the issue
right
i've just had a face lift um a brow lift
a temple lift
an eye surgery a camphor plasti um
and teeth as well oh wow just these are
just part of my transition um
i'm feeling really good i'm for the
first time in my life i feel beautiful
you know i'm looking in the mirror and i
love the way i look and feel happy
um and my pronouns are they them korean
jimin
even jimin
that is on the next level i'll
i'll say that bruh imagine this becoming
the status quo and i'll just get
canceled
yeah he can be another person so why you
[ __ ] bigot
what okay you identify as another gender
or non-binary okay fine
so what i don't care do what you want to
do but they this
is uh korean jimmy
i try to think about it what would it
look like if someone
someone transition as a swede oh god
mad world but i do identify as korean
and i do look korean now
i do feel korean i don't identify as
british so please
don't um refer to me any media or anyone
online as british because i
i identify as korean that's just my
culture that's my home country
home country how did that oh god this
is so strange my home country is korean
you can't decide i mean hey you can't
decide where you're born right
i guess i assume korea is kind of
similar to japan we're in the sense that
you kind of stick out as a foreigner so
it's it's hard
to feel like you're not a foreigner when
you're in these countries right these
asian countries
so i guess ollie just decided no you
know what
i am part of the gang okay and you can't
stop
me i'm coming out bro i wonder what
jimin thinks of this
sorry to interrupt just wanted to remind
you guys that the tambourine cap
it's a key camp we're making 6 500 of
these look out
look at it so cute okay
look so detailed they all spin the
rooney feel the ultimate power
of hitting the escape key button
whichever button you want
by smashing one of these it's a limited
edition only 6500 available
last one sold out so link is in the
description if you want to pick one up
i mean there's always been people like
this right that do surgery to look at
as other people this is in general
nothing new
i think the whole changing race thing is
an interesting
factor in all of this i'm speechless i
don't know what to say it's so bizarre
i wonder what an actual korean thinks of
uh of this
here we go korean reacts i identify
myself as
a black person
mate that is beyond
impossible please tell me you're joking
dude like i wish
this guy just comes out after like a
decade or a couple years from now saying
yo this is all
a troll i was trolling the whole thing
okay well you know he's not trolling
because he's doing
actual surgeries hip-hop nation the
korean whatever
it was our joke right no way
ali if you're watching this you can't be
korean because you're not
you don't have why do i have to explain
this to you you can't be
korean because you're not korean
okay all right well that answers that
question you know people online
like youtubers they would say oh he does
things retention like
nobody would do this for attention
nobody would go through this much pain
this much suffering i've had 18
surgeries in total
for the last eight years nobody would do
that to themselves potentially i'm doing
this because it's
how i identify it's how i feel no i i
believe that he's doing it because he
wants to but you're also you know
letting everyone know
right you you cannot say you don't like
the attention at least
which is fine if you want to do that but
i don't buy that
at all there's definitely both of these
elements playing into each other
i just want to say i hope this video
might encourage other young people that
have been really struggling with who
they are
you know always always do what makes you
happy in life this is my message this is
my
see i agree with that but the problem is
that people don't always know what
what will make them happy if everyone
knew then everyone would be happy
so jimin also came up with a flag
which is a korean flag in a rainbow
they them they slap core ian
i mean it's almost not even funny i'm
just here to flabber i guess
of course i know i was born in the uk
but for me i feel
feel more korean than british but you
don't have any
korean ancestry or dna
no not officially but i just feel like
these days there's so many different
ways you can identify people
people can identify as like a disney
prince or an animal
which some people do some people
identify as aliens like why can't i
identify as korean i don't see why
people seem to have an issue but
he makes a point but i mean you're
appropriating another race it's not oh
that's not always a good look i'm not
gonna lie
you're not taking away from aliens by
[Laughter]
identifying as the how does jimin get
money for all of this as well
i need to know i've just been attacking
me non-stop you know they're
preaching about oh don't bully people
online look after mental health yet
they're
the same people attacking me online so i
just don't get why there's such a
backlash
well i'm sure a lot of it it's just
criticism but i he has a point here i al
i also see this online of the same
people preaching for like oh don't bully
are the same people that bully
i mean i guess you could argue i you
know i say that too and
you could argue that i'm pulling jim in
here but that's not my intention
well i just feel these days 2021 we
should be able to embrace who we are
be who we want to be and as long as
we're not hurting anybody which i don't
feel like i'm hurting anybody the korean
people
love me they're obsessed with me well
that's not what i saw online
but okay sure you can't be korean
because you're not
korean race is always a sensitive
subject especially when people have
experienced racism but uh
people need to be a bit more
understanding and open-minded because
you know it's 2021 we can express
ourselves in different ways
i don't know if i like 2021
can't tell he's taking the piss out of
everyone
and the walk mob he's having a laugh i
doubt it i doubt it people are saying
just stop
talking about it as if then he wouldn't
do it i still think he would do it
but i think he likes the jimin likes the
attention
korean boy band bts
how can you identify as another
individual explain that one to me
well i've had so much surgery i've had
18 procedures i've had so many
non-social procedures two look like
jimin so that's why i've decided my
career name is jimmy the gemini
jimin is a member of this band bts
yes jimin's the singer and i've based my
looks on him i based my life because i
interviewed him before actually
i wanted to ask me take me along with
you next time
but but how do you think jimin will feel
about this
because he's jimin now you're saying
of course he's the original german i
just feel like i'm like his twin or
something but i think he would maybe he
would find it a bit weird some people
would find it weird if somebody has
surgery to be like them yeah but
i think also he'll be very honored
korean people are always honored when
people take an interest and
yeah i get it i've had a lot of surgery
to look like him i live my life as if
i'm him
i think he'll be honest i mean i hope it
happens i mean please take me along to
your next interview i'm i'd just love to
see his reaction
do you not think you'd be happier trying
to be you ollie
no you know i've i've never been happy
with who i am i've always had issues in
terms of my looks my appearance
um self-esteem issues and i've never
been happy and
it wasn't until i moved to korea i
started transitioning to have the korean
look
that i actually found happiness so now
for the first time in my life i actually
feel happy
see how long that's gonna last until the
next surgery right that's always the
issue isn't it it's just
sad to look at well that's what's new
with ollie london i
guess you know what i'll take this off
i think i'm good
[Laughter]
no no hate don't it's intended with this
video don't
don't go tweeting [ __ ] or send to ollie
that's not the point of this video i
just think it's interesting
it's an interesting story it's weird how
i'm totally fine with people
doing surgery or if they're not happy
about an aspect of themself
fine but it also kind of opens up this
question you know what
are you ever going to be you know if you
can always change a part of yourself
i somehow sincerely doubt this is the
end of the
cherbocals so yeah what do you think let
me know
i'm curious thank you for watching
videos smash like subscribe
yeah see you next time